Welcome back everyone
it's charlie obviously it's still a very
sad time everyone's still grieving
chadwick boseman the marvel people just
posted their official tribute to him it
aired last night on television so i'll
play that video in a second here
what i'm going to do is the same thing
as my last video and just donate the ad
revenue from this video to a cancer
charity
if you do have one you want to recommend
just let me know in the comments so
here's marvel's tribute video to him
that aired on television last night
it was chadwick boseman's performance in
42 that really made us take a second
look there is
there is such an honor and dignity to
the way that he played jackie robinson
that we knew we needed for the character
of t'challa the prince of wakanda
chadwick is an amazing actor that we
thought would fit perfectly
with the mcu
black panther himself ladies and
gentlemen mr chadwick boseman
chadwick you know he has a lot of
depth it was amazing as an audience
member to
you know to look into his eyes and see
what's going on we must
find a way to look after one another
as if we were one single
tribe a lot of the things about the
character are also true about chad
he's very knowledgeable he's an athlete
you know a martial artist
he's had a lot of experience playing
roles that come with a lot of weight you
know so i think he has a he has a person
he has a guy has a lot of
has a lot of weight to him i think he
brings all that that stuff to the role
not to mention that he's incredibly you
know incredibly gifted as an actor and
as a performer and also as a storyteller
in his own right i am not
king of all people i am king of wakanda
and it is my responsibility to make sure
our people are safe
because he is so prepared as an actor
and because his character is sort of
flawless on set
it forced the other actors who had
scenes with them to kind of raise their
game
and go okay this guy is not taking
anything for granted he's really leaving
it all out there
so we have to keep up with him what
doesn't chadwick bring to the character
i mean he's regal and grounded and he
brings a gravitas to it
so all of this feeds his t'challa and
i think he wore the crown with dignity
he brought him back
i've known him since i was about like
17. so i've known him for a really long
time
um back in new york he did the work
obviously
you know i just think he did an
incredible job being true to the
character
i had a great time with chadwick just
warmth and camaraderie came into it of
course with a great deal of respect for
his previous work
so when i looked at him with proud eyes
you know
they were as mother and and also as as
comrade and colleague and angela it is
your time
to be king i mean chadwick is just a
powerhouse
he really is so talented every single
movie he's made there's there's kind of
this
internal almost nobility the black
panther has been a protector of wakanda
for generations
he's such a soulful actor and um
so professional so present he really
gives so much
to the other person and he's awesome and
his presence on set
i think makes that kind of raises the
stakes a little bit for everybody
chadwick is a he's a really smart
interesting dynamic guy
and i think he was not overwhelmed but
very surprised and somewhat taken aback
by the amount
of love it ceased to become just about
how well he inhabited the role and all
that stuff it's become part of our
culture just as a symbol
this welcome is is one of the most
amazing things i've ever experienced
it's fun to watch just what it means to
people
at times like in my head i'll be like
well
what does this do for the world like
actually what is it
you know is it actually valuable in this
climate and i have to say
yes it actually is not because it makes
people escape
i think when done right um it gives
people hope
i found that it means a lot
so that was all the avengers actors all
the bigger people at marvel the
executives the producers just paying
honor to his memory
they aired that on abc right after they
got done airing the black panther movie
commercial free ryan coogler the
director of black panther who was
featured during that memorial video also
issued his official statement he was
very close to chadwick
boseman but he's not active on social
media and he was just so much more
broken up over the weekend that it took
him a couple days to get his thoughts
together to issue an official statement
and memorialize him so it was a very
long very touching statement i'm just
going to read part of what he said here
he says he was a special person he would
often speak about heritage and what it
means to be african when preparing for
the film
talking about the black panther movie he
would ponder every decision
every choice not just for how it would
reflect on himself but how those choices
would reverberate
they're not ready for this what we are
doing this is star wars this is lord of
the rings
but for us and bigger he would say this
to me when we were struggling to finish
a dramatic scene stretching into double
overtime or while he was covered in body
paint doing his own stunts
or crashing into frigid water and
foaming landing pads
i would nod and smile and i didn't
believe him i had no idea if the film
would work
i wasn't sure if i knew what i was doing
but i look back and i realized that chad
knew something that we all didn't
he was playing the long game all while
putting in the work and he did
chad deeply valued his privacy and i
wasn't privy to the details of his
illness
after his family released their
statement i realized that he was living
with this illness the
entire time that i knew him because he
was a caretaker a leader
a man of faith dignity and pride he
shielded his collaborators from his
suffering
he lived a beautiful life and he made
great art day after day
year after year that was who he was he
was an epic firework display
all tell stories about being there for
some of the brilliant sparks till the
end of my days
what an incredible mark he's left for us
but is with a heavy heart and a sense of
deep gratitude to have ever been
in his presence that i have to reckon
with the fact that chad is an ancestor
now
and i know he will watch over us until
we meet again
signed ryan coogler so it's a very
wonderful memorial and he talks about
working on the black panther film i
think a lot of people were surprised to
hear that ryan coogler someone who
worked so closely with him for so long
and so intensely on a movie like that
didn't know that he was suffering from
cancer the whole time
i talked about it in my last video but
he actually found out that he had been
diagnosed
stage 3 cancer back in 2016 around the
time the captain america civil war was
happening
so he filmed all these different movies
not just the marvel movies like avengers
end game
avengers infinity war the black panther
movie but a whole string of other big
films
indie films and in between those just
went through incredibly invasive and
intensive surgeries and cancer
treatments
just taking it all like a champ you
rewatch some of these films this was all
happening while avengers end game
avengers infinity war was happening even
the black panther movie
and he looks fantastic you wouldn't know
it just to look at him
one of the reasons why he probably
didn't want to tell a lot of the people
that he was working with that he was
suffering from this
is that it winds up coloring people's
perception of you the industry
in everything you do just becomes about
that not about the work or the mark
you're trying to leave
and a lot of people have been talking
about the impact that his characters and
the work that he had had on people
around the world and he didn't want to
take that away from any of those people
but it's so wonderful just listening to
all the other big time avengers actors
that have been around this whole time
talk about what a special person he was
and how much he inspired them coming in
and completely changing the landscape of
not only the marvel cinematic universe
the marvel movies but just pop culture
and cinema in general
i would encourage you to watch some of
his other films if you haven't seen
anything besides his marvel movies
they're all fantastic he's fantastic in
everything that he does
what'll probably happen in the future
because marvel has the black widow movie
that they plan on releasing later this
year
is they might attach some sort of
memorial or card to that movie
remembering him they did the same thing
for stan lee when the captain marvel
movie came out
but they will find some way to get some
sort of memorial into the upcoming
movies
it's just that right now they only have
the black widow movie coming up later
this year and then the eternals movie
early next year
i think it's a little crass to be
talking about black panther 2 right now
but i'm sure
sometime next year they'll address
what's going on with the future of the
marvel cinematic universe they will give
it the appropriate amount of time to
settle so that they are not
disrespectful to his memory
so if you didn't see it i also posted a
chat with boseman video this past
weekend after they announced the news of
his passing you can click here to watch
that
and you can click here for all my other
marvel videos thank you so much for
watching everyone please stay healthy
and safe i'll see you guys tonight!